وفي نشرتنا ايضا تعهد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو بان
حكومته ستواصل الحرب على البرنامج النووي
الايراني كما شدد على ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ستعمل على تعزيز وتطوير
الاستيطان في جميع انحاء ما سماها ارض
اسرائيل في الجليل والنقب والجولان والضفه
الغربيه قائلا ان هذا حق حصري للشعب
الاسرائيلي لا جدال فيه وفق تعبيره وكان
نتنياه قد قدم الاتفاقيات الاحتلافيه
الموقعه مع الشركائه في الحكومه الجديده
للهيئه العامه للكنيسه التمهيدا لنيل
الثقه وتنص هذه الاتفاقيه على تعزيز
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه وتوسيع
المستوطنات الخليل على وجه الخصوص
بالاضافه الى العمل على تشريع قانون لفرض
عقوبه الاعدام ضد الفلسطينيين المتهمين
بتنفيذ عمليات ضد اسرائيليين واجراء
تعديلات قانونيه بسحب الجنسيه والاقامه
وترحيل كل الفلسطينيين ينفذ هج ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه
وكان الكنيست الاسرائيلي صدق على قانون
يقضي بتوسيع صلاحيات زعيم تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه المتطرفه اثمار بن جبير كوزيرا
للامن القومي وجاء تصويت على قانون
القانون ضمن تعديلات قانونيه اخرى اجرها
لائتلاف الحكوميه وسبقت توقيع زعيمه
بنيمنه نياهو على الاتفاقيات الائتلافيه
مع شركائه في الاحزاب الصينيه الاحزاب
الصهيونيه الدينيه
والدينيه الحديديه هذا سيعرض نتنياه غدا
حكومته على الكنيسه التصويت من اجل النيل
الثقه
معنى من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوى نسبرين
جوان ما المتوقع اذا بالنسبه لنتنياهو
وحكومته
وبن جفير
اليوم الانتهاء من التوقيع على
الاتفاقيات النهائيه بعد ان كان نتنياهو
قد وقع مع شركائه في الائتلاف الحكوميه
المقبل مسودات لهذا الاتفاق خلال
المفاوضات ولكن فجر هذا اليوم اتم نتنياهو
التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيات مع الاحزاب
الاخرى بطبيعه الحال نتحدث عن حزبي
المتدينين الا يهود شاس للمتديين الشرقيه
والابرز هو بطبيعه الحال همم التحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه بزعامه المتطرفين مثل
الالسموتر
هذا تم هذا اليوم اقرار وتصديق على احد
القوانين اللي كانت التي همم شرط همم
يتم التصديق عليه قبل همم تقديم الحكومه
لنيل الثقه وهو قانون يقضي بتوسيع صلاحيات
ثمار بين كبير كوازير للشرطه الاسرائيليه
وقد حول اسم هذه الوزاره من الامن الداخلي
الى الامن القومي ومن خلال هذا القانون
حصل بين كبير على صلاحيات للسيطره على
قوات حرس الحدود العامله في الضفه الغربيه
والتي كانت تخضع
للجيش الاسرائيلي جيش الاحتلال من جهه
اخرى سيكون وفق هذا القانون ايضا همم بني
كبير هو من يتحكم بالمفتش العام همم
الشرطه الذي سيكون خاضعا اللي هو هناك
تعديلات كثيره اخرى تمنع تمنح بني كبير
صلاحيات واسعه في هذا الايطار قبل ذلك يوم
امس ايضا تم همم همم
التصديق على قانون اخر ايضا خصيصا من اجل
التوقيع على الاتفاقيات على الائتلافيه
يتعلق باريادر زعيم حركه تشيلسي له ان
يتسلم منصبا وزاريا رغم ادانته بجرائم همم
فساد مالي متهم بها هذا بالاضافه الى
توسيع صلاحيات ايضا المتطرف
بالترش فيما يعرف بالاداره المدنيه التي
تقوم بتنسيق عمليات حكومه الاحتلال في
الضفه الغربيه وعلى هذا تحديدا هناك
احتجاجات واسعه من قبل رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي كان له محادثه
مطوله مع رئيس الحكومه المكلف باليمين
نتنياه وصفت في الاعلام الاسرائيلي بانها
استثنائيه في العاده رئيس اركان الجيش لا
يتدخل في السياسه ولكنه احتج على صاحب هذه
صلاحيات وتحويلها لبث ال سم وترتش غدا
سيتم عرض هذه الحكومه على الكنيسه للتصويت
عليها ونايل الثقه من الخطوط العريضه التي
نشرت حتى الان لهذه الحكومه هي خطوط معلنه
فقط عثمان لكن من الواضح انه هناك بنود
كثيره شكرا لم يتم الاعلان عن عنها تستجيب
لمطالب المتطرفين في هذه الحكومه بني كفير
وسمو تريش وايضا للاحزاب الدينيه المتزمته
شكرا جزيلا لك من القدس نجوان السمري